go
bonjour à tous bienvenue notre émission
sportive inform chimie collages sur
votre coach aujourd'hui sam avec le
natal ou bien est ce que tu es en forme
pour le mouvement qu'il arrive et
j'espère que vous aussi vous êtes prêts
derrière vos écrans pour le mouvement
qui va suivre un mouvement très simple à
réaliser avec une marche ou un banc en
dynamique alternez alors matin je vais
te montrer le mouvement derrière ou
d'écran regardez bien au niveau
technique ensuite quand tu aurais je
rectifierai un peu les erreurs qui en
argoat sûrs que vous devrez ensuite
serment correspondants nous alors vous
démarrez avec un pied sur la marche ou
sur sur le banc c'est vrai les poussées
sur la jambe avant et vous déplacer à la
verticale et alterner une jambe après
l'autre pour flécher sur la jambe
d'appui et vous poussez la jambe arrière
amorti légèrement le mouvement et vous
montez vous l'utilisez les bras
également pour un mouvement un peu plus
fonctionner l'ata la loi allez vas-y tu
mets ton fier sur la marche est partie
nrb
très bientôt soixante agents ma vente
amortie bien le choc tu penses à gainer
assez raide et à biot et à garder la
fraîcheur droite enlevant la poitrine
ok très bien elle va sortir sur ce
mouvement elle va vous le dire à la fin
d'un mouvement très cardio d'aller là il
ressentir énormément au niveau du coeur
brûler beaucoup de calories et
solliciter les gros muscles des membres
inférieurs les fessiers les cuisses et
les jambes c'est bon tu peux t'arrêter
de la dame de la merci comment tu toi
c'est ce qu'il faut alors nous allons
maintenant au pouvoir les étirements
correspondre à ce mouvement va te le
démon dans un premier temps et tu
effectues derrière très simplement vous
allez vous servir de nouveau de cette
marche placez le talent sur la marche et
les clés main sur votre cuisse reculer
les hanches pour retrouver la longueur
au niveau des ischio jambiers garder la
posture droite en enlevant la poitrine
et vous pencher le must en avant à
partir des anges aller à toi
vous mater cette position une vingtaine
de secondes sur chaque gens
m
en fait servir au niveau zéro place
l'autre jambe et bien des fins au niveau
des hanches les proches par la boue
et
le relâchement merci le natal pour les
étirements complémentaire à ce mouvement
veut nous retrouver sur les autres
émissions minutes auront la tâche je
remercie pour ce mouvement leur voix à
ses jours à bientôt au revoir tout le
monde pas très bientôt dans des couches
et les missions et les formes fente
dynamie entraînez-vous une à deux fois
par semaine en effectuant de deux à
quatre séries de 5 à 20 répétitions
attention à la mauvaise réception
toujours effectuer une flexion de jambes
au départ et à la réception